oh God
I want to see you I just I can't even
tell you this is we haven't seen each
other in how long 25 years 25 years
yeah last time I saw you I partied we
didn't party we got sober together we
got unsober together we got sober
together yes I know and I'm still like
in the middle what happened what
happened no no it's like trying to
figure it out that's what happened we're
always trying to figure it out until the
day we die because life is an ongoing
Journey right and we try to learn and
grow and soak it all in and hopefully
grasp something right like we were such
kids together you know like sometimes
I'll say to people like we were just
kids like it's a kind of a euphemism we
were in our 20s we were kids we were
literally kids yeah do you remember our
first days
um
no tell me you really don't remember
well I might when you reboot the memory
because I have so many memories can I
tell this story
okay all right so what happened was I
get a call one day my grandmother says
uh uh we got a call from Steven's office
and the little girl from ET wants to
meet you because she's got a crush on
you oh yeah I did the biggest true story
but everyone did oh thank you I didn't
feel that way you know I didn't feel
that way because I was very insecure and
you were not really I'm a little bit but
I'm over it a little bit but that's what
made me love you because I you know
loved the idea of you and I loved you as
an actor and a human but getting to know
you I that's what I was always drawn to
was your lack of ego and we were around
many nice people but many people who
fell prey to self-indulgence right and
you didn't okay so Stephen
so well not Steven himself but you know
someone in his office yeah yeah yeah
right and they're like yeah so uh the
little girl for me to you know Drew
Barrymore and so I'm like yeah I know
who Drew Barrymore is of course yeah and
they were like well she's got a crush on
you yep and her mom was wondering if you
guys would be able to get together and
go like on a little play date like a
cute little played it right and I was
like okay yeah that sounds fun let's do
it you know so uh we arranged for me and
of course neither of us drove because I
was still living at my grandparents and
you were living with your mom yep and uh
years away from getting our licenses yes
indeed I was
I believe 12 or 13. and you were 10 or
11. yep so that was the little Gap there
yeah I meant it when I said kids yeah we
were literally kids so and it was so
cute so like I remember taking you to
the movies I remember exactly which
movie theater it was it was uh the one
next to the Gelson's parking lot uh I
think it's on Balboa yes on Balboa and
Encino yeah remember that they used to
have that little three Cinemas right
there right across from the Gelson's and
we parked at the Gelson's and we walked
across the street and you put your
little hand up for me to hold and I held
your hand and we walked across the
street
I don't remember what movie we saw
but I remember all that oh my God that
was the first and then after that we
just stayed friends yeah
and then it was years later before we
actually dated yes right exactly like
dated properly do you remember going to
like the Academy Awards together I
remember you were going and so I was
lucky enough to be your date and I just
threw on like a cotton Betsy Johnson
dress off the rack you know I don't know
how much it cost probably 65 dollars it
was probably more than I could afford to
buy you at the time so you know and I
remember getting there and I remember
seeing people in such designer you know
Duds yeah and I remember looking around
and thinking oh I'm very underdressed
I was wearing a cotton Betsy Johnson
dress whoops 60s but you know what you
were a kid what are they gonna do be
like get that kid out of here she's not
dressed properly what does she know so
cool thank you well you know what I was
wearing my safety pin jacket oh I
remember and a red shirt and your
Ray-Bans and like I just thought we were
having so much fun that picture it's
everywhere it's legendary yes absolutely
we were such the great little cute
little item for like the you know three
months we lasted or whatever but it was
adorable but we were so positive you
know you and I were such good friends we
it's like we had that kind of
relationship where they say like date
your friend you know we were the
embodiment of that you were so kind you
were such a safe place for me and we
always hung out with your friends and
you had an apartment and we just like
had it was just a really important place
for me and the memories are so beautiful
I remember so here's the other part of
the big memory was that you were already
getting your life together and I was all
those safer than probably most of the
Hollywood people around us at the time
but I was you know still going through
my troubles so you got sober first you
got your act together first it took me a
few years after you well then I like on
got it together and I got it
the point is is that we actually did
take a moment to catch up and be on the
same playing field because you had it so
I'm so grateful to see you me too me too
I'm so happy
I love you
and now that we're reconnected you can
call me anytime ditto
[Music]